أعلن الرئيس أردوغان يوم
الأربعاء أن تركيا اعتقلت زوجة
زعيم داعش السابق أبو بكر
البغدادي الآن ، وليس من الواضح أين
حدث هذا عندما حدث ذلك أو
أي من زوجات البغدادي المتعددات
كان هذا ، لكن ذلك يأتي بعد يوم من
قول المسؤولين الأتراك إنهم أسروا أبو بكر البغدادي.
أخت أبو بكر البغدادي زوجها وزوجة ابنها
في مداهمة على
حاوية سكنية هنا في بلدة اعزاز شمال سوريا
تحدثنا الآن إلى مسؤول
من الجيش السوري الحر في
الجيش الوطني السوري كما هو معروف الآن.
وأخبرنا أنها انتقلت
إلى المدينة منذ حوالي ستة أشهر كانت
تتظاهر بأنها لاجئة وأن العائلة
جاءت إلينا كما لو كانت بوثائق مزورة
وحاولوا الاندماج في السكان المحليين
للنازحين داخليًا وهم
قلقون من أن  قد يكون هناك الكثير
ممن يحاولون فعل نفس
أعضاء داعش السابقين وأفراد عائلات أعضاء داعش
ويقولون إنهم
يبحثون عن ذلك الآن
يعتقد المسؤولون الأتراك أن  تعتبر هذه
الاعتقالات الأخيرة منجم ذهب استخباراتيًا محتملاً
يمكن أن يمنحهم
نظرة ثاقبة حول كيفية عمل داعش في
الوقت الحالي ونوع التهديد الذي
يمثله على تركيا وبقية
العالم.